the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so Tuesday we developed the largest
equation that you'll probably ever use
at MIT
Thursday we destroyed it down to a
rather manageable size and today we are
going to solve it and actually show you
guys how to work out different reactor
problems all the way from simple one
group homogeneous reactors to expanding
intuitively not directly from the
mathematics to solve or to pose and
solve to group reactor problems like the
one they did beyond the ap1000 reactor
where they separate the neutrons into a
fast and a thermal group and I wanted to
put up where we left off we have some
equation describing fission N and
reactions photo fission absorption and
leakage or diffusion as the big balance
equation for how many neutrons are there
in some reactor and I think last time I
had some example reactors up on the
board ranging from an infinite slab with
a thickness a to a cylinder with we'll
call it a thickness a and a height Z and
the question that we want to be able to
answer is if we draw a graph of flux
versus X through this reactor and in
this case it would be R and Z what do
these functions look like what is the
form of this flux and so today from this
equation we're actually going to solve
it so they'll bear with me they'll be
maybe 20 minutes of remaining derivation
and I'm going to teach you how to use it
so today's class is going to be more
like a recitation of how do you actually
use this equation instead of getting to
it first of all I want to simplify
things which is going to make it D
escalate if we simplify things and don't
worry about these ni n reactions and
photo fission we have the equation that
you'll actually see in your reading I'm
gonna drop them for now and I'm realize
I'm missing one little gamma because
they're just extra terms they were
instructive in writing the neutron
transport equation because all the terms
looked similar but now they're just kind
of extra things for us to write and the
last thing that isn't in units of flux
is this laplacian operator for those who
don't remember and this laplacian
operator takes different forms in
different dimensions and different
coordinate systems for 1d cartesian it's
pretty easy
it's just double derivative let's say in
X for a cylindrical it's significantly
uglier plus d squared over D so this is
what the laplacian operator looks like
in a the case of a finite cylindrical
reactor so first we're gonna focus on
the infinite slab case right here
because it's a lot easier to solve
analytically and then we'll show you how
it would go for the cylindrical reactor
which looks a lot more like the reactor
as you see everywhere else in the world
so let's start doing a little bit of
rearrangement and isolate that laplacian
so we can then subtract d del squared v
from each side
okay and that cancels those out and then
we've got something on the left hand is
in del squared Phi and on the right side
has all in units of flux so then we can
divide everything by the flux and if we
then cancel out all the flux terms all
two of them we're left with something
awfully simple and the last thing we can
do is divide by D on both sides and I'm
sorry I had to cancel that flux cuz
that's the way that goes the DS cancel
and I'll redraw what we have right here
so we have minus del squared flux over
flux equals constants and what that what
are they actually would be 1 over K
times nu Sigma fission minus Sigma
absorption over D everyone remember why
we're putting these bars on the cross
sections and D and everything can
someone just tell me that's right we've
averaged over all energy so some average
cross-section would be the average from
our minimum to our maximum energy of
that cross section as a function of
energy times flux over the range itself
so by this we're saying we're averaging
the cross-section somehow over the whole
energy range now I asked you guys what
sort of functions in Cartesian space
happen to have its double derivative
over itself equal to constant is what
Exponential's or sine and cosine you've
basically said the same thing two
different ways yeah because the series
is because the the plus and minus
Exponential's can be rewritten in sines
and cosines so if we now assume that our
flux solution has to take the form of
let's call it a cosine B X plus C cosine
what's the next constant F X I'm sorry
that's a sign I don't want to use D
again for obvious reasons and E stands
for energy so that's the next letter
that we haven't really used the flux has
got to take this shape or else this
condition is not satisfied so this is
the like easy way of solving
differential equations which is guess
the solution from previous knowledge or
experience or something so based on this
if we were to draw a flux profile let's
say right here was x equals zero one of
those terms has got to go away by
reasons of symmetry what do you think
it'll be so which of those halves right
there is symmetric about the x-axis
right here sign with a cosine
cosign yep the signs it's it can be
inverted around your coordinate system
but it's not symmetric it's not a mirror
image so actually the sign term goes
away and we've got to have some solution
which looks like a times cosine B of X
because right here our D flux DX should
equal 0 at x equals 0
now I've intentionally drawn the flux
not to go to 0 at the very edge of the
reactor if the flux automatically went
to 0 at the edge of the reactor there'd
be no need to shield it right so there
actually is there are some neutrons
streaming out of this reactor and this
distance right here is actually equal to
2 times the diffusion constant and this
is what we call let me get rid of the
stuff we don't need anymore this is what
we call the extrapolation length
and now I should also mention I'm not
going to derive it because I think we've
done enough deriving for one week but
I'll just give you the form this
diffusion constant can actually be
expressed in terms of other
cross-sections where this mune ah'd is
what's known as the average scattering
angle cosine and it approximately equals
2/3 times the average atomic mass of
whatever it's scattering off of so this
D that I've just introduced from some
physical analogy actually has an
expression from cross-sections and the
material properties that you can look up
so we've now turned it into some sort of
condition where everything can be looked
up in the janice library or whatever
cross section library you have plus
whatever number densities you actually
have in your reactor so what's starting
to pictures started to get very real and
very physical so now if we assume that
Phi takes the form of a cosine BX let's
plug it in so if we rewrite this
expression I think I'll need another
color for a substitute so we'll take a
cosine BX and stick it in there and
stick it in there and we'll end up with
minus del squared cosine is going to
look like a times B squared cosine BX
over a cosine BX equals those constants
starting to get very simple I'll keep
the bars on there because they're quite
important and if we cancel things out
the cosine V X's go away the A's go away
and we're left with whatever is inside
that cosine B squared equals a bunch of
material properties there's no
information in here about the geometry
of our reactor there's only the material
properties whereas over here this
constant B I'm going to add a little G
to it which stands for geometry and
we've now set up a condition where if
you know the geometry and the materials
in the reactor you can solve for the
final unknown which is its K effective
how critical or not is this reactor so
what would be have to be to make this
cosign valid so what would be G equal if
we have the form of this flux like so
I'll give you a hint if the cosine goes
to zero right here at some reactor
length a over 2 plus some extrapolation
length 2d then how do we make the cosine
equal to zero at this point
what does BG have to equal
quite close it would have to be BG would
have to equal PI over a over 2 plus 2 D
such that when you substitute or / / -
right yeah oh yeah okay so that when you
substitute x equals a over 2 + 2 D into
there this cosine evaluates out to 0
that make sense
cool so now we have BG there's nothing
here but geometry plus a little bit of
extrapolation length right here yeah oh
yeah this should be an over 2 so that
when you plug in x equals a over 2 plus
2 D you get PI over 2 + cosine of PI
over 2 is 0 yep cool so now we have our
BG so we substitute that back in there
let's just continue to call it BG since
we have it over there and we have this
much simpler expression BG squared
equals 1 over K nu Sigma fission + Sigma
absorption over D then where's our
rearranging color we can multiply
everything by D and let's see that
should have been a minus copied myself
over wrong the DS go away you can then
add Sigma absorption to each side then
those go away and then you can multiply
everything by K
and those go away and finally divide
everything by Sigma a plus D B G squared
and what we're left with is our
criticality condition our K our
criticality is pretty simple
new Sigma fission over absorption plus
leakage so finally after all that
derivation we've arrived at some
intuitive result remember we said that K
the criticality or the K effective is
the ratio of gains to losses of neutrons
so that's exactly what we have the only
gain mechanism right here is by fission
and the lost mechanisms are either
absorption by the stuff in the reactor
or leakage outside of the reactor and so
this is actually how you tell when the
reactors in perfect balance is if this
condition is satisfied and if it equals
one then the reactor is critical so now
we can start to play with this and say
let's say we started off with a critical
reactor and all of a sudden we were to
boost the absorption what should happen
to K effective if you just start
observing more right it should go
subcritical now mathematically speaking
that means this denominator gets larger
so this ratio gets smaller and therefore
K effective has to go down as well
now that's an easy case let's start
exploring some of the more interesting
ones let's say you raise the temperature
in the reactor do we necessarily know
what's going to happen next let's work
it out so most cross-sections when you
raise the temperature will actually go
down in value due to a process called
Doppler broadening that you'll learn
about in 2205 but suffice to say for now
that cross-sections tend to go down with
temperature the most important reason
why is because a cross-section is an
for density times a microscopic
cross-section and if the temperature
goes up then the density goes down and
the number density goes down and if the
number density goes down the macroscopic
cross-section goes down the atoms just
spread out from each other so regardless
of what happens at the microscopic
cross-section which I'll leave to Ben in
court to teach you next year
we know that the macroscopic
cross-section goes down because it gets
less dense so let's try and work out now
what would happen to K effective so what
will happen to nu if we raise the
temperature nothing let's hope what
happens to Sigma fission it goes down a
bit but what about Sigma absorption
Sigma absorption is gonna go down
does BG change has the geometry of the
reactor changed probably not might have
thermally expanded by a few nanometers
but let's just say it doesn't change at
all what about the diffusion constant
let's work that out Sigma total is gonna
go down
Sigma scattering is gonna go down so
probably what's going to happen is this
diffusion constant is going to go up
which means that if the atoms spread out
more neutrons will move farther on
average hopefully that makes intuitive
sense as if the cross-sections go down
then a neutron can move farther before
an average interaction so the diffusion
constant is probably going to go up
which way does K effective go you're
correct
no one said anything because you can't
really say anything so it depends on the
relative amounts that these increase or
decrease so depending on what you choose
for your materials you can have what's
called positive or negative temperature
feedback which means in some conditions
or scenarios what you want to happen is
that if the temperature goes up K
effective should go down but not
necessarily so depending on what you use
you can actually have situations where
raising the temperature raises K
effective and
is some seriously bad news and is
actually outlawed you can't design a
reactor with positive temperature
coefficients so this is the first little
taste of reactor feedback is now that
we've written this criticality condition
we can start to explore what happens
when you start probing the reactor so
let's say what happens if you just add
more reactor in this case where's my
green all the way over there without
changing the materials what happens when
you make the reactor bigger what
increases decreases or stays the same
let's just work it through does new
change Sigma fission no Sigma absorption
D how does BG change
b:g decreases and as you'd expect if you
add more reactor to your reactor the K
effective should increase and so this
hopefully is starting to follow some
intuitive pattern we're the given
criticality condition in some situations
you can work out well the reactor gain
or lose power speaking of where's the
power where'd it go yeah so yes the
power comes from the kinetic energy of
neutrons but where did the power go in
our expression yeah
that's right that's exactly right and
follows directly from the math this a
got canceled away it doesn't matter you
can actually have what's called a zero
power reactor so the power of the
reactor and its criticality are not
necessarily linked you can have a
reactor that is critical while producing
tons of power you can also have a
reactor that is critical while producing
I won't say zero but an infant testimony
small amount of power and they actually
have built these they're great test
systems for testing our knowledge of
Neutron physics because you've got a
reactor that's producing maybe ten watts
of power it's you know easy to cool by
blowing a fan on it let's say but you
can still measure the Neutron flux in
different places and test how well your
codes are working with a much safer
configuration than sticking probes into
a gigawatt commercial reactor yep
that would push the reactor out of
steady-state indeed so on Tuesday we're
gonna start covering transients and if K
effective becomes something other than
one the reactor is no longer in steady
state it's not an equilibrium because
the gains and the losses are not equal
to each other and at that point the
power will start to change what you guys
all saw when you manipulated the reactor
power so since you brought it up does
anybody remember if we draw as a
function of time let's say the reactor
power was cruising along and right at
the time as now you withdrew a control
rod what happened when you guys did that
anyone cuz he all did it went up okay
and then what when you stopped
withdrawing the control rod did it level
out so everyone tell me what happened it
slowed down the increase but it didn't
stop going up kind of freaky so this is
why I had you guys do that power ramp
because just you you know controlling a
reactor is not as simple as remove the
control rod you remove a certain amount
of reactivity because there are time
dependent effects due to delayed new
Tron's neutrons that aren't immediately
released after fission that can have a
large effect on how you control your
reactor and then if you wanted to
decrease it again let's say you put the
control rod back into its original
position
the power would not come back to its
original position but then eventually it
would start to Coast down and probably
go beneath its original position at
which point you have to constantly be
controlling those control rods to keep
it in what I'll call dynamic equilibrium
you never really hit static equilibrium
unless it's off as a I went to a seminar
a couple weeks ago and said I don't
study biological organisms and static
equilibrium because that's better known
as a dead organism they're not very
interesting but dynamic equilibrium
shariah is for them and for us so with
this process of getting the single group
balance equations I'd like to generalize
this to the two group balance equations
and this is something you can actually
use in every case we're going to say
let's put our games on the left and put
our losses on the right if we want to
have this reactor in equilibrium and now
we'll separate our equations into the
fast and thermal regions of neutron
energy so we'll call those F and we'll
call the thermal ones th so using this
model of our Neutron diffusion equation
what are the gains of neutrons into the
fast spectrum
yeah straight from fission so how do we
write that and this process that we're
going through now this is where
recitation really begins because this is
how I want to show you guys how to
approach a problem let's say a one
sentence statement like give me the flux
anywhere in a two group reactor this is
how we go about it so how do you
equational II put the neutron gains from
fission well what terms we have up there
right now yep
yep you'll have your new your Neutron
multiplication factor and now we're
actually going to split every cross
section into its fast
and thermal energy ranges because now
we're actually splitting that energy
like we did when I drew that crazy cross
section let's say we had log of E versus
log of Sigma and they all follow roughly
that formula and we split it and said if
we want to draw an average cross section
it would look something like this and
that would be our Sigma thermal and this
would be our Sigma fast so that's what
we're doing here so now it gets a little
more complicated because Bost pfaff both
fast and thermal neutrons can contribute
to fission so how do we write this in
terms of equations
we only want the neutrons that are born
into the fast region the fast gains that
doesn't mean you don't have to consider
where the thermal neutrons because it's
mostly those thermal neutrons that when
they get absorbed and make fission
create fast neutrons so what we'd really
need is Sigma fission fast times are
fast flux because we're gonna split
every variable into its fast and thermal
parts plus let's put a parenthesis there
Sigma fission Thermal Phi thermal so do
you guys see what I've done here we're
assuming that every Neutron is born in
the fast group where we're cutting this
off at around 1 Evy and we are assuming
that no neutrons are born below 1 Evy
which is a very good assumption so in
this case both the fast and the thermal
fluxes contribute to creating fast
neutrons is there any other source of
fast neutrons good because I don't know
one either
okay what about losses by what
mechanisms can neutrons leave the fast
group yeah yep they can be absorbed so
how do I write that
af times the fast flux so only neutrons
in the fast flux group will leave the
fast flux group by absorption and what's
the other mechanism that we had in our
Neutron diffusion equation
yeah actually so that's not in the
diffusion equation but you are right
that's the missing piece that is gonna
be the hard part so let's add that in
now so there's going to be some
scattering from the fast to the thermal
group times our fast flux so not every
scattering event will cause the neutron
to leave the fast group but some of them
will so we have to figure out what is
the proportion of those neutrons that
will scatter from the fast group to the
thermal group for the case of hydrogen
it's pretty easy because the probability
of a neutron landing anywhere from zero
to e starting off at energy e I if we
had our scattering kernel is a constant
so that's not too hard and then last one
other way can we lose neutrons from the
fast group yep leakage they can leave
the reactor and we can write that as a D
fast be d squared flux make sure
everything has bars that needs them okay
now using the same sort of logic let's
yeah Luke
it's not it's the same it is the same BG
that describes the geometry of the
reactor G means geometry yep
and you had a question yes thank you
that is a fast flux yeah but it's
important to note that this flux right
here is not a fast flux we'll get back
to that soon now using the same sort of
logic let's write the gains and losses
in the thermal group so what is the only
source of neutrons into the thermal
energy group now I want to hear from
someone who hasn't said anything yet
so Jared what would you say either Jared
so I haven't heard from either of you
you did okay then you I'm sorry yeah all
right yeah you said the no power thing
thank you close I want to replace one
word in what you said if something is
blank in the fast spectrum and goes down
to the thermal spectrum yes scattered
every Neutron that leaves the fast group
by scattering enters the thermal group
also by scattering and in this case we
want to have the fast flux appear here
because the number of neutrons entering
the thermal group depends on how many
scatter out of the fast group yeah Luke
you'll see yes yeah
great yeah I gave something away yes you
can but no you usually don't so we would
consider that once neutrons entered the
thermal group there at thermal
equilibrium with the stuff around them
and up scattering is rarely a
possibility you'll see yeah quite soon
actually don't worry not like quiz
you'll see but you'll see yeah
I already I've already got some stuff
planed out um it's gonna be a part of
the homework question so now what loss
mechanisms do we have yeah
leakage so we're gonna have some
separate thermal diffusion coefficient
because that diffusion coefficient
depends on the cross-sections which
depends on the groups you're in times
the same geometry times five thermal and
what's the only other mechanism of loss
absorption we've got a clear a why is
there no scattering from the thermal
group
you say things very very
I'd say even simpler once you're at the
bottom there's no more no more lower you
can go so you know in neutronics when
you hit the bottom you don't say throw
me a shovel you say you're at the final
energy group so now what we'd like to be
able to do is last thing we want to
stick in is our K arrows our K effective
our criticality because reading reality
this is kind of what we want to know in
terms of the geometry and the materials
in the reactor so if we know what we
make it out of and how big to make it we
should be able to get those in balance
such that K effective equals 1 so the
only really unknown here besides the
flux unknowns is K and the reason I
don't care about the flux unknowns is
they're gonna go away soon yeah
absolutely because the K effective is on
the bottom of the total original sources
of neutrons just like let's see that was
one group yeah so I'd say right now this
this accounts for the production of all
neutrons and everything else down the
chain is losses yeah mónica
we know experimentally that they tend to
be born between 1 and 10 MeV but since
you asked let's escalate the problem and
then we will de-escalate very quickly
just to say let's do a thought
experiment right let's say some of the
neutrons were born thermal what would we
have to add to this expression there's
one variable missing that's not anywhere
on these boards but was there on
Thursday and Tuesday that's right Chi
the birth spectrum so if some neutrons
are born thermal then we would have to
add a chi ear and we would have to add a
chi thermal to say this is the
proportion of neutrons born fast or
thermal times nu times Sigma fission
fast v fast plus Sigma fission thermal v
thermal and I'm not writing nice because
I'm just gonna erase it in a second but
to go with your thought experiment this
is what it would look like if some of
the neutrons were born thermal perfectly
fine thing to model doesn't happen much
in real life but great exam question for
next year thank you
next year I'm not going to give you your
own exam question that's just too easy
for you so for now let's forget about
that stuff and stick with the most
realistic situation running out of room
already okay
that's for next week so let's forget
about that what do we do next we have
two equations three unknowns interesting
or do we really well for one thing if we
can get that top equation all in terms
of one of the fluxes either faster
thermal then every term is in terms of a
flux and they can all be divided out so
let's take one of these equations and
substitute in so that we get everything
in terms of only one flux so let's say
the top one which has got two K in it
has one instance of five thermal so
let's isolate five thermal in terms of
everything else so we have that thermal
equation right there so we have Sigma
scattering from fast to thermal times
fast flux equals two things times five
thermal which is d thermal BG squared
plus Sigma absorption Thermal we're
actually not that far away so all we do
is we divide each side or is my
simplifying color substitute that's not
it
rearrange divide everything by this
stuff
and those cancel out and we're left with
an expression for Phi thermal which we
can now plug into that top equation so
we're like one step away from the final
answer there everything's still visible
and so now we end up with one over K
times nu Sigma fission
fast-fast
plus 2 Sigma fission thermal times this
expression Sigma scattering fast to
thermal my flux over D thermal I don't
usually spend this much of the class
with my back to you but this is pretty
mathematically intense so I apologize
for that
and equals Sigma absorption fast fast
flux plus D fast be G squared fast flux
that's not a bar that has one that has
one that does that's good ok
now every single term here is in terms
of fast flux so we can just cancel them
from every single term here and now
we're left with an expression for K
effective that's just in terms of
material properties in geometry for the
two group problems it's actually we're
only one step away so if we multiply
everything by K and divide everything by
this stuff we'll just have a Sigma
absorption plus D fast VG squared
that would equal K and just like that is
the criticality condition for a two
Energy Group homogeneous reactor of any
geometry all that matters to define the
geometry is what's this BG squared so
this case works for an infinite slab
reactor it works for an actual right
cylindrical reactor you just have to
solve for or look up the correct
buckling term this BG squared which I'll
tell you now we refer to as buckling or
geometric buckling and you've got the
solution to this let's just check to see
what we actually have here we have new
material property material property all
of those are material properties except
for the BG's so this tells you how to
design a reactor physically and in terms
of which materials to make sure that
it's critical and if we look at what
this looks like here again it's a ratio
of gains to losses because eventually
the losses right here these are the
losses from the fast group these are the
losses from the thermal group these are
the gains in the fast group noting that
some of the neutrons born in the fast
group scatter out of the thermal group
but don't leave the reactor so again it
turns out to a gains / losses ratio and
there you have it so I want to stop at
10 ophea
it should be did we yeah let's stick it
in right here
so we'll just also stick it here
there and that flux goes away because it
was in terms of everything yeah there we
go thank you okay but again this
represents losses on the bottom gains on
the top just like any other K effective
so I wanted to stop here at 10:05 of and
answer any and all questions you guys
have about going from the neutron
transport equation all the way to
something that you could solve and then
start to play around with to say what
happens if I switch isotopes what
happens if I raise the temperature what
happens if a chunk falls off of the
reactor and it gets smaller it's yeah
yes
somewhat we we can assume that for you
know considerably long enough times and
to a neutron a long time could be like
seconds that the time and the spatial
form of the flux are separable which is
something that we'll talk about on
Tuesday but if you remember one of the
major assumptions we made in the neutron
transport equation with steady state we
got rid of any transient effects we'll
bring them back now that we have a way
simpler case on Tuesday yeah Luke from
fast to thermal
or it is that going
let's see oh yeah we / all the stuff on
the right so I didn't we okay so that
shouldn't be there but it should be
there because we / everything on the
right side let's just check that really
carefully so it should have been that's
the thermal one so we're not worrying
about that yep so it would just end up
here yeah good point
cool let's talk a little bit about what
I'd want you guys to be able to do with
this so what what I want you to be able
to do on the homework and on an exam
with the Neutron transport equation
recited from memory
no not really but if I were to give you
the neutron transport equation I make
you want you to explain what some of the
terms mean or tell me how you would get
the data or explain one of the
simplification steps and justify why you
think it's okay because we actually
wrote out the justification for every
step on the board or explain for example
what's the physical reason that we can
solve the neutron transport equation
with this diffusion approximation and in
which regions does that approximation
break down so can anyone tell me from
yesterday where is the diffusion
equation a bad approximation of the flux
yep
near the control rods or the fuel or
anywhere else where cross-sections
change all of a sudden because diffusion
describes kind of like long distance
steady-state solutions across places and
where things change drastically
diffusion kind of breaks down because we
assumed here that the neutrons behaved
like an ideal gas or some chemical
species with no neutron to Neutron
interactions because the mean free path
length for those interactions is like
what do we say ten to the eight
centimeters so a mega meter yeah I love
using those sorts of terminologies
thousand kilometers before a neutron we
hit another neutron or I might ask you
to let's say reduce the neutron
diffusion equation and come up with a
simple criticality condition or let's
say if you were to make a physical
change to the reactor
tell me if you think it would go more or
less critical in what would happen next
or I could give you a different physical
situation like the up scattering
scenario which I will and ask you to
pose and maybe solve these equations or
at least get forms of the criticality
condition I'm not going to ask you to
get tons of flux equations because
that's all 22:05 is about is doing this
sort of neutron physics but I want to
make sure that you walk into that class
prepared plus we've been kind of heavy
on the you know this class that the name
of it is intro to nuclear engineering
and ionizing radiation and so we're far
we've been pretty heavy on the ionizing
radiation in physics well this is where
the engineering comes in assuming you
have some material properties you can
now pick them to create a reactor in
perfect equilibrium yeah Kristen no so
did anyone else have any questions about
the material or about what I might ask
you to do with it yeah so you said this
yep so all that you would do differently
is right here when we had that laplacian
operator we took the one dimensional
case of an infinite find an infinite Sri
actory and finite in one dimension which
meant the laplacian operator is just
double derivative of X but you could
pose the equation in cylindrical
coordinates and say well let's say now
you had an infinite cylinder reactor you
wouldn't necessarily have sines and
cosines that would satisfy this relation
anyone happen to know what you'd have
the sines and cosines of the cylindrical
world called Bessel functions so these
are the sorts of in cylindrical geometry
equations that behave similar to Kaia
sines and cosines with kind of regular
roots and that you can describe in a
similar way but I'm not going to get you
guys into that I'll just say okay there
exist solutions that you can look up in
the cylindrical case and I would not
make you derive them by hand because
what's the point again I'm not here to
drill your can you do the same math over
and over again I want to make sure that
you can intuitively understand what's a
K effective in a sentence its gains over
losses what happens when you push that
out of equilibrium or what physical
situations could push that out of
equilibrium so any other questions from
you guys yeah
it would look pretty similar in our it
would kind of come down like that it
would always be symmetric about the
center for symmetry arguments and in Z
it would look kind of like that and so
actually in the end the form of flux in
R and Z comes out as the first Bessel
function let's say that's a times the
what would you call it times cosine of
this distance is Z so PI Z over and have
to add a subscript and there'd be some
constant a in there so what you can
assume for multi-dimensional reactors is
that the dimensions are separable so the
R part is solved separately from the Z
part and that comes right from the
laplacian operator right here you assume
that the see if you assume that some
flux in R and Z can be written like the
are part as a function of R times the Z
part as a function of Z then the
solution gets a lot easier to deal with
but this is not something I'd ask you to
do in any coordinates but Cartesian
because those are more intuitive and
you'll get plenty of the other stuff
later
they're called Bessel functions
yeah so if you want to look up there's a
little bit about them in the reading but
it's one of the more advanced topics
that I'm not going to have you guys
responsible for much rather it be you'll
be able to tell me what happens if you
compress the reactor or raise its
temperature or pull out a control rod or
you know raise the pumping speed and
cool down the water or something like
that so there'll be plenty of those
kinds of questions on the homework to
help reinforce your intuition as well as
some of the noodle scratchers we'll be
developing a criticality reaction or
equation for a more complex system than
the one I've just shown you here but
using the same methodology in the same
ideas